many coachman is a real estate mogul who
has been collecting cars nearly his
entire life today this collection is
worth over 30 million dollars and he has
another 17 million dollars worth of cars
coming in at first glance he seems like
a passionate middle-aged rich man who
doesn't mind splurging on his hobby but
in reality his car collection is much
more than just this in fact he made
eleven thousand eight hundred seventy
five dollars per day in profit from his
Koenigsegg supercar which he owned for
five months so how does many coachman
make money from his cars
[Music]
generally we're told that cars are the
worst investment one can make and that
they're just an endless money pit they
start depreciating the second you drive
the mouse a lot but the real killer is a
maintenance cost on high-end cars as
they're often playgroup reliability
issues and all of this is true for the
average car so the first step to making
money on card is to buy cars that are
not average in Manny's case many of his
cars are actually the only ones in the
world
for example the Koenigsegg many sold is
the fastest street-legal car in the
world and only 25 were ever made on top
of this man he was able to get the last
one made called the Phoenix and talked
down several lavish upgrades including a
$300,000 rear wing plenty of 24 karat
gold accents and the carbon fiber wrap
evidently all these characteristics made
the Phoenix the only one of its kind in
the entire world and given this manny
was able to buy it for 2.2 million
dollars and turn around five months
later selling it for 4.1 million he
actually tried to get five million for
it but that was a bit too much
nonetheless he was able to profit 1.9
million dollars which conversed eleven
thousand eight hundred and four dollars
per day in appreciation similar to the
Koenigsegg Phoenix many as several cars
that are only ones in the world for
instance his five million dollar Bugatti
Chiron Hermes Edition is not only high
watering but also one of one just like a
seven million dollar Pagani Hermes
Edition so though the average car
suffered severely from depreciation
Manny's cars don't because there are
collectible cars in Manny's case his
cars are top-of-the-line sports cars but
this is not the only type of collectible
cars collectible cars can also hold
historical significance like the first
Model T car ever produced or be
associated with a certain celebrity like
Paul Newman moving on
not only does many buy collectible cars
but he also takes very good care of them
in the past
he is detailed that he spends one
hundred fifteen thousand dollars a year
just to get all of his car serviced
along with all changes he also spends
$36
to get all of his cars detailed and
cleaned on a weekly basis and of course
insurance is not cheap across all of
these cars he says he got a very good
deal of insurance which he very well may
have but despite that insurance still
costs $100,000 a year and what about his
garage he says it costs one hundred and
eighty thousand dollars a year just to
maintain his garage which is Specht out
with 700 thousand dollars of technology
ensuring his cars are kept at top
condition all of these early costs add
up to four hundred and thirty one
thousand dollars per year but all of his
maintenance is not the key to keeping
his cars appreciating the key is not
driving them and keeping the mileage low
which many also does he only has a few
hundred or a few thousand miles on most
of his cars especially most expensive
ones and the few times he does drive his
expensive cars he's very careful to keep
them clean
in fact he were shoe covers before
driving a Bugatti Chiron Hermes Edition
and with all these sacrifices and
investments Manny is able to keep his
thirty million dollar car collection
appreciating but you may be asking what
is a point of having so many cars and
not fully enjoying them well - a lot of
car collectors the answer may be to make
money off of them or just a fun of
collecting them the thing is many isn't
necessarily looking to make money off
these cars when he sold the Koenigsegg
he stated that he had no plans to sell
it and that he was simply offered a
price that he couldn't refuse
so Manny isn't trying to collect cars to
make money off of them in Manny's case I
believe he maintains his cars as
investments to find a nice balance
between enjoying them while also not
blowing millions of cars he would
otherwise not buy you see though many
coachmen is quite wealthy this car
collection is still a very significant
expense for him Manny coachman does
control over two hundred and fifty
million dollars worth of real estate but
this is not meanness net worth is also
this much his net worth is estimated to
be around eighty million dollars so
logically it doesn't make sense to blow
nearly half of your net worth on sports
cars that provide just dumb fun as a
result many cleverly only buys unique
one
of a kind cars he didn't go out and buy
a bugatti chiron right when i came out
he even declined that shear on
Supersport 300-plus he only buys the
most exclusive cars and maintains them
very well and in the end he's a BOS had
two birds with one stone many is able to
get the best cars in the world while
also getting cars that will at least
hold her value and that is why many
coachman uses his cars as investments it
brilliantly allows him to indulge in his
hobby here and there while also not
placing his entire fortune in jeopardy
if you guys thought this video explained
man his car collection well they measure
drop a like and consider subscribing to
see more questions logically answered
but until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one